in these remote woods a show of modern
military muscle
the finnish army joined by units from
britain america estonia and latvia
this is a crucial juncture for the host
country after long decades of refusing
to sign up finland is now poised to join
nato
the reason
fear of russia
the two countries share a border that
runs for more than 800 miles
where once finns were dubious about nato
now they are quietly enthusiastic
i think we're gonna find a way to
keep things peaceful
by joining nato i guess
i'm saying yes
i think it's a good thing
it's we can just
bring more to nato and nato can bring
more to us
not far away the british challenger two
tanks the biggest in this exercise here
to practice and to extend an overt hand
of friendship
it's good to learn from each other and
as everyone every country does it
slightly different so it's nice to see
how they
they would go through with some actions
compared to how we do it's definitely
good for learning
the finns plan to join nato along with
sweden
both would then be protected by the
famous article 5 which dictates that an
attack on one nato member is considered
as an attack on all it is exactly the
sort of concerted response russia feared
it's now threatening to deploy troops
and even nuclear weapons to the baltic
region
this is a military exercise it's a phony
war but it's been conducted against the
backdrop of a real brutal war in ukraine
and what's happening there has huge
repercussions for finland a country with
an enormous border with russia
when this nation does join nato it knows
russia will be furious
britain's defense secretary was here
today and alongside him his finnish
counterpart
i asked him why nato had suddenly become
attractive
we are especially interested of the
article five of of nato
and uh
that's the that would be the main reason
to become a member of nato
nobody wants to tell finland how to
behave but it's clear britain sees value
in a bigger stronger nato bloc the
security of europe is very important for
us all the security of scandinavia and
nordic countries is incredibly important
because it is our flank
and therefore we will do whatever
necessary it is to stand by our friends
in the nordic countries
britain is not alone in its enthusiasm
the momentum behind nato expansion is
hefty
but russia will react weapons and
politics will merge
yet again
adam parsons sky news western finland